[Applause]
all right what else we got we got this
black ass bachelor
yo what if chappelle's whole thing was
about the black bastard
now that tune in for my man look a
little corny to me but what's the deal
so for the first time i believe in 19
years of the bachelor history they have
their first
black bachelor okay
timing the timing seems a little well
they had a
black bachelorette yeah maybe just took
a while to find one without a kid
[Music]
no but there was a black bachelorette i
remember i watched her season like a
year ago right yeah
yeah i didn't watch it i forget her name
she was a beast but didn't the show
start as the bachelor and then they
switched over to yeah sure but like
the reason why there hasn't been a black
bachelor i think since or bachelorette
since because she had the lowest rated
season
so that was like two years ago yeah this
[ __ ] gonna be low two where should i
watch it does she look good you know
if they pick like that i'm not saying
america is racist but bachelor fans are
racist
yeah that's a fact like that's the
racist part of american life because
that's a fantastic american's not racist
but the higher rated show on television
they're racist yeah yeah all right so
100
bro for real son the lowest rate of
season was this black girl
and she was dope she was like a lawyer
she's smart as [ __ ]
she was like dumb bimbos yes pretty
pretty you crack i mean in the back of
the day back in the day would i crack
i mean i'm taking down some [ __ ]
ducklings
this is
some girls have gotten a lick off of me
bro you know what i mean real quick
they're so proud of it no i took down
some [ __ ] voldemorts
i took down some beasts they broke they
put a multivitamin in your ass
now you know i never had a girl put
anything in my ass tongue got licked
i got that lick but yeah so they and
they're they're upset at this guy
because they wanted this other guy mike
yeah mike
i watched that season you know what was
he good yeah i don't know
everybody seemed to like him i didn't
get it yeah yeah so here's the thing
and this is incorrect my phone is not in
a relationship yeah i've noticed
you're going to find out about the
[Applause]
i don't have none of the like reality of
a one harry potter relationship
just get back in a relationship bro i'm
done harry
i mean you are in a relationship that
white girl stayed in the u.s for two
more years you know what's going on in
the bachelor you don't watch every
episode
you come in the room it's on you sit
down you leave
you know what's going on yeah but you
remember the dudes that were on i
remember the black dude that was on it
obviously
respect fine ass
so why didn't they pick that dude so i
have a theory about this i have a theory
about this too
you go first okay uh i think that
they're look i think the other guy
has more black features oh and
this guy is soft this guy is black but
he's racially
ambiguous in his face so like his
features don't look
specifically black now the other guy
dark skinned indian
yeah he could be indian he could be
latino you're not exactly sure he's kind
of like one of those shampoo commercials
where they like
the girl you know what race she is so
all races could be like oh head and
shoulders work for me
right so i think that that's what they
did i think they did a lot of testing
the other guy on paper is actually
perfect he's like a wealth manager
he was in the air force he's like the
ideal american
husband right but i think that his
features
are more black and i think that these
[ __ ] racist execs
or maybe they're not even racist but
maybe these executioners the fan base
the these the racist fans are like oh
i'm not gonna watch it because i don't
see myself
marrying him i don't see myself in him
and this is a real thing
white girls watch this [ __ ] i want to
say something that like has happened to
my friends and i've experienced
white girls [ __ ] black guys they date
black guys
and then they hit their late 20s and
that's the i want to settle down age
and then they stop doing it and i've had
friends have gone through this i'm not
gonna shout out the homies but like
they've literally experienced like just
banging black
blank white chicks all the time they
love them it's a great thing they dated
relationships etc and then as he's
gotten older all of a sudden
the age range of girls he's been [ __ ]
hasn't really
elevated with his age because the white
girls in that age are like
uh i kind of want to settle down with
this white guy like i know i'm woke and
i'm progressive we did all this [ __ ] but
that was my fun time
i want to have a white husband and do my
white pick offense etc
and this show is aspirational this show
is who would i marry
how do i see myself in these person's
shoes and because
the other guy i think looked a little
bit more whatever traditionally black
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ] that means
i think they're like no no throwing a
racially ambiguous guy out there maybe
they could see themselves with him
that's interesting um do you think
that's more pressure from the actual
girl or from the family
fan uh fan base no family oh like
why the girls stop dating black guys
when they want to settle down i think
it's i usually think it's
pressure from the family i think it's
family but i think it's also like
culture
trickles down so i think like that
pressure of the family ends up becoming
who they are
just like racist breed more racist
devil's advocate
yeah what is and so this guy that was on
the bachelor before made it really far
was really popular
wouldn't it theoretically hold over if
he became the bachelor
like people already like him he has
cachet you know him
done that wholesome sway 100 it
absolutely could and they could be
making
a huge mistake again these executives
are making these moves just to keep
their jobs yeah i think they're [ __ ]
up
yeah and i think they could be [ __ ]
up because they should they could be and
i could be
uh misinterpreting how supportive they
would be towards that other guy
yeah you know so i think there's like a
couple things i think that's probably
true
but this dude had so like the way like
the bachelor works i guess is like
there's like a community that happens
once you're in the [ __ ]
yeah like you become a part of like this
greater zeitgeist yeah so he
was on the on the football team with
another guy that was supposed to win
so like this dude tyler cameron was
supposed to win he was like the favorite
and then he lost and this dude was like
his best friend
like off the show [ __ ] up yo yeah
that's
it's for real so he got this cosign from
the guy that was supposed to win
and then on top of that the girl that
that girl hannah brown
said the n word on on alive yeah and
then got a bunch of heat
for like you rapped along to a song and
said that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah white
girl pouring to clarify that yeah but
like got
a ton of heat from like the bachelor fan
base and all these people going crazy
this is like before george floyd even
like two weeks
and then as a result of all like the
bachelor he black lives matter all that
[ __ ] they were like all right we have to
pick a black dude
and i don't think they necessarily
wanted someone with that's already been
on the show
that has like baggage that like goes
along with being on the show
but michael doesn't have baggage
apparently apparently everybody loved
him he
got far and he was like super enjoying
super like i i
literally think like on the executive
level these shits because they have no
talent these execs
they just run everything through focus
focus group focus group focus group and
they focus group
michael i'm sure and then they focus
group this guy and they're like who
would you see yourself with
who do you see yourself in and then all
the guys that watch are like yeah
probably relate more to that guy because
literally his face is just similar
looking in shape
and if the audience that watches it is
80
white or 90 with some absurd amount
white
i think that they're like okay let's
just go with this guy and it could be
wrong
what did you mean he's supposed to win
like this it's rigged already
no no but like he literally picked a guy
who like broke up with a girl in the
middle of the show that he was dating
throughout the show and he there's
she has text messages of him being like
yo i got to do this is good for my
career
that guy won and then this other guy
started [ __ ] gizelle or something
like that after
not giselle not gizelle who's the [ __ ]
hadid or something like that
yeah like he he's running through
[ __ ] now he's like a guy
she started following him off of the
show they went on dates like how do you
get on the bachelor's side
yeah who [ __ ] who am i
she pregnant right now yeah yeah i think
they were like on again off again or
something they like went out on dates
there's like pictures
my girl keeping me posted thank god she
settled down with finance zane you know
what i mean good for you gigi
is he hey half i'll take it
that's a come up but she's probably
indian too or something like that she's
muzzy i think he's happened
but just like to make up for all the
years they didn't have black people they
should
he should start with one and end with
30. he should start with one
yeah start with one girl and end with
all three
like you got to make up for all the
years that we didn't right yeah
um is there anything that would look
worse for black men
than cheating on 30 minutes at the end
of the show like that's how it ends i
mean you want to be authentic